l'ogre du petit poucet peut se mettre
aux légumes verts et le grand méchant
loup se trouver un job bozo les séries
cultes des 8-12 ans sont aujourd'hui
peuplée de monstres gluants de
marionnettes maléfique et de parents qui
ne sont jamais là
[Musique]
tiab woods et un diffuseur déjà numéro
un au hit parade américain des fictions
pour enfants la série de la fox chair de
poule fait un carton sur notre petit
écran laissant perplexes certains
parents et donnant de gros frissons à
leurs enfants
c'est déjà et bien ce genre de séries
parce que bon on a peur on regarde là
comme ça et pire on ne peut pas on ne
sait pas ce qui va se passer des fois on
croque un truc horrible et en fait ces
porcs est franchement un peu mal à
l'aise mais sinon non salées qu'est ce
qui te fait le plus peur là dedans c'est
qu'on a vu c'est dingue tout ça ça va
faire peur c'est ce qui me fait le plus
peur dans la vie d'imaginer quelque
chose puisque une image au cinéma ou à
la télévision on sait que c'est qu'un
film comme ya des bouts un peu de bruit
dans ma chambre j'imagine qu'un gros
monstre qui vient et je m'imagine qui me
prend qui m'emmène des trucs comme ça
est ce que tu aimes ça avoir peur
j'adore
bah c'est excitant on se voit à voir pam
en même temps c'est drôle oui mais
parfois quand tu es dans le noir n'ont
pas trop ouais
à l'origine de chair de poule un succès
mondial de l'édition
190 millions de livres vendus en cinq
ans plus de 3 millions en france chez
bayard
[Musique]
je suis à dix tonnes l'auteur des chars
du pool
[Applaudissements]
le monde réel et effrayant beaucoup plus
effrayant que mes livres je ne cherche
surtout pas mes sujets dans ce monde là
ça gâcherait le côté distrayant des
sujets comme le divorce l'alcoolisme les
drogues ou la pédophilie
tous ces sujets graves n'ont pas de
place dans mail
promener les enfants suivez moi
peut-être stein at il compris que
l'imaginaire des enfants s'envolera
toujours vers des mondes où ils pourront
combattre leurs propres monstres
[Musique]